make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting into the war of
realms part two and again like I'm
really digging war of realms like I'm
digging the hole for war of rome's story
right like and it's okay here's the
reason why what makes the war of realm
so awesome is that like everything in
Jason Aaron's run led up to it that's
what made it so cool if you liked watch
you see a character here named Dario
Agron we'll talk about him he was a
character who popped up in the very
early stories of Jason Aaron on Thor
it's cool to kind of see all those
little tidbits sort of brought back in
but one of the things I do want to draw
your attention to is Jane Foster now the
way this picks up is again it's
basically like all these forces of
Malekith right like is about that's one
of the things to bear in mind
Malekith is basically organized and
brought in all these forces from like
all the other realms and use it to
invade earth now the front face at
Malekith puts on is well i just wanted
to save earth for last but the reality
of it is that earth is home to some very
very powerful people some very very
powerful characters but showing up with
like a whole house of basically like
armies from Muspelheim from the realm of
Surtur in the land of the Dark Elves
like all these forces that Malekith is
brought to bear has basically like
landed in New York and it's a full-scale
panic
it's just evacuation let's get out of
here as soon as we can and a lot of the
people are basically traveling into dr.
Strange's sanctum sanctorum right
because one of the things about when it
comes to dr. strange is home is that
it's well it is a confined space it does
have like closets and doors and in
little rooms or things like that that
expand on for like eternity right so we
can house like an endless number of
people but for Jane Foster herself a lot
of you guys will notice Jane Foster is
alive
and a lot of you are probably scratching
your head in terms of how is that
happening because Jane Foster died it
was literally a story called the death
of the Mighty Thor the way this worked
out was that after Jane Foster had died
that what Thor had done is he had
basically taken like the storm inside
the hammer of neil near and tried to use
that as a means to basically resurrect
Jane Foster and then of course once odin
jumped in
then of course Jane Foster was brought
back to life now the reason for why Jane
Foster was allowed to live again was
because of the sacrifice she made to
save the Asgardian so essentially what
it meant is that as a warrior people
like she was willing to sacrifice it
actually did sacrifice her life in the
name of protecting those who needed her
help but basically died like a Warrior's
death and we know that because her soul
went to Valhalla and so she was going to
be accepted into Valhalla proper but
once everything popped off and basically
like you know the the forces of Odin and
Thor were able to resurrect her she was
brought back to life and cured of her
cancer now the reality is that that took
me by surprise I thought she was just
gonna die and like that would be the end
of Jane Foster
I'm glad she's back because it makes it
leaves room for her to become Thor again
which is something I'd really be excited
about but from here it switches over to
like the Punisher and this is one of the
coolest things right because you have
the main forces right like you've got
like the the angels from from from the
tenth realm or from you know the realm
of heaven basically which we'll talk a
little bit about that here in a minute
but then you've also got like these
soldier guys who were just kind of
mopping up everything else and like as
they're going through like of course
because Dark Elves have a weakness to
iron they can't stop the Punisher and
then like one of them is like why why
are you guys feeling so disastrously
this is like a guy how could you
possibly not be able to kill a guy and
they're like because he has an unlimited
supply of iron and he's just like mowing
everybody down with machine guns who the
Punisher is a beast not only that it's
actually the Punisher and Wolverine
teaming up it will actually cover that
in a different video but it's pretty
awesome to see them working together
Captain America of course jumping in
you've got Iron Man you got the Avengers
but one of these I want you guys to
notice here is this really kind of like
we're doing the best we can but we're
not doing much because when it comes to
the Avengers facing off against you know
earth earthbound threats usually what
you expect is something along the lines
of like hey here's like a singular being
who's a threat to earth not like an army
of hundreds of thousands if not millions
of forces you just invade the planet and
start attacking everything now one of
the other big reasons why New York is
being conquered so easily is because the
x-men aren't here number age of X the
story that nobody's reading is currently
going on right now and so because that
whole thing taking place like the
uncanny x-men in terms of like a full
legitimate roster is basically gone
you've got Cyclops and Wolverine and a
smattering of other characters and like
that's all you have an uncanny x-men
right now the mutants are there they're
doing whatever it is that's going on and
age of action that's it but if we had
like a full contingent like all the
uncanny x-men oh the battle would shift
dramatically because the cuz mutants are
just so powerful but again it's kind of
a cool little thing to see here one of
the things that also hits on is Dario
agar now the idea is that that with
Avengers and mountain there's all kinds
of tools and resources they can use
right like that's the New Avengers
headquarters we saw that in the first
video we did on Avengers which you'll
find down in the description when they
basically kind of change the origin of
the universe and all that kind of stuff
and like they they basically exist
inside of a giant celestial more or less
but because of the fact that they're cut
off the reason for this comes from Dario
Agron and that's why I say it's cool to
see him kind of make a return so Dario
agar is basically like the leading guy
with Roxxon Oil and rocks on oil is like
this hyper corrupt organization right
that basically has his hand
and like everything if it comes to like
like any any illegal activity you can
imagine rocks on oil has a hand in it
but given the resources of rocks on what
they've done is hacked event heck the
Avengers HQ and then shut off their
ability to like teleport anywhere really
do anything so they're essentially stuck
in New York or lessor they can they can
leave but like in terms of getting all
their resources to their availability
they're kind of stuck here now at this
point things get kind of interesting
because what we do is we switch over to
Doctor Strange and then like the coven
of witches of Malekith now Malekith does
have war witches and the war witches are
very very powerful the problem with the
war which is is that typically they
should not be able to defeat Doctor
Strange right like that's the big kind
of thing is is at this point the mantle
of sorcerer supreme when it comes to
Doctor Strange it's really more of like
a title than an actual role he lives up
to and the reason why is that while he
is the most powerful sorcerer or the
most powerful practitioner of magic on
earth you see these stories
intermittently where he's like not the
most powerful sorcerer in the universe
and by virtue of being the sorcerer
supreme he's supposed to be the
universe's most powerful practitioner of
magic but over the years Marvel's kind
of shifted that up now he's a lot more a
lot more limited which makes the stories
a little more interesting because you've
got to kind of find a way to write a
story about a guy who's the sorcerer
supreme I can do almost anything but not
really and then make it compelling which
of course we've seen done before but in
this instance with him being sorcerer
supreme that name kind of flies in the
face of the idea that like he should be
the strongest person there but he's not
because this coven of witches are able
to basically kind of shut down his power
to a degree basically block access to
different different things for Doctor
Strange to be able to pull off and it
makes it kind of intriguing because if
the word witches are really that strong
and the realm of the Dark Elves is
outside the main Marvel Universe well in
a different dimension in the universe it
should still apply right because like
Doctor Strange is the most powerful
practice a practitioner of magic in this
house and that closet over there in this
house is where these war witches are
from so technically speaking he should
be more powerful than them but again
it's the nature of Doctor Strange it
gets a little finicky and it gets a
little strange you've also got
enchantress facing off against against
Ghost Rider
now while Robbie ray is is not
technically Johnny Storm or Danny ketch
still the fact remains that like as the
Ghost Rider he's basically powered by by
hell fired by Mephisto and so it stands
to reason that he should be able to
topple enchantress and it's kind of
interesting that he's not there's a
little bit of a consistency here but
again it's not a great big huge deal as
it was kind of a cool little thing
because following all this while all
this is happening you said
have owed UNS showing up here with a
valkyrie now this is a dangerous game
and the reason why is that while the
valkyrie are exceedingly powerful the
valkyrie are the women who Shepherd the
souls of those who die in honorable
battle to Valhalla but with them being
here on the Battlefront what this is
designed to do is basically say it's a
last-ditch effort every single warrior
that can be used by the Asgardians is
being thrown into this fight because
that's how capable this whole thing is
and that's where it's very easy to lose
focus of all this is that when you're
talking about like this this whole
conflict going on you're essentially
talking about various beings out there
who in some in some degree have power
akin to thort if not a little more
powerful or a little weaker but by and
large almost all these guys who are
fighting on behalf of Malekith are all
stronger than your average Avengers are
stronger than Captain America they're
stronger than like Iron Man or any of
those guys all these guys are
exceedingly capable and so again because
of the fact that the coven of witches is
ultimately taken down by Jane Foster
what this does is it allows Doctor
Strange to essentially like uses magic
and then essentially like create a giant
gateway of sorts that allows like all
these various people who were still here
instead of funneling into his house grab
them all and snatch them all away the
problem with this is that this is a kind
of power dr. strange doesn't use very
often what it does is it drains him by a
huge margin so he's essentially just
like totally exhausted Doctor Strange
has to rest odin of course has to rest
and is basically marshalling all these
forces and creating the groups that are
gonna branch off to face off against
these various characters now we kind of
knew that by way of the solicitations
right we saw like there's war of realms
one and war of realms two and then you
start branching off into the little
titles right so you have like the war
Scrolls books and different things like
that you've got like the various forces
who go off to achieve various goals one
of these groups is going to serve the
purpose of going to Jotunheim and
finding thort other groups will serve
other purposes but this is usually how
that pattern goes right like we've seen
that play out in a wide array of
different crossovers over the years of
Marvel Comics in Civil War you had
Captain America's Secret Avengers you
had Iron Man's Mighty Avengers and then
you had the actual like Iron Man
Avengers group proper doing its own
thing
so again like in this scenario where you
literally have Jane Foster watching
everything unfold what we end up finding
out here is that Brunhilde him she
basically been killed and the question
is being asked is if like all the
Valkyries are dead then what happens to
those who die an honorable battle where
do they go you know is there there's
because there's nobody there to Shepherd
them to Valhalla which means their souls
will never truly find peace it's it's
basically one of these things where it's
like we don't know what to do now like
all the characters who really sort of
chance to
Malekith are essentially out of the
picture right now you got a smattering
of people here in there but none of
these are like really heavy hitters and
that's kind of what they need to a
degree things are really bad is
basically what this means things are
really really bad now the one thing I
will say here this was kind of ironic
about it is it doesn't really seem to
show that you don't really feel that
it's just like it really kind of seems
to lack the idea that like things are
really really dire for the superheroes
to get toned a kind of emotion really
comes to be lost a little bit but again
it's actually kind of cool to sort of
see the story to take place because one
thing that I really don't like when it
comes to events is it like oftentimes
every single issue will in on the note
that like and this is when everyone dies
you kind of get tired of that so what is
kind of a cool feeling to see it sort of
continue on but again you know I'm
loving warm realms it's pretty awesome
like it's it's it's pretty amazing I'm
really big in it but we have being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come this
explain miss you guys at the sub button
to become part of the rock or if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and I will catch you all later
peace